Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Warner Brothers
announced plans to reboot the Harry Potter movies
with a totally new cast in the next several years
and there have been lots of reports about them
doing a separate big TV series on HBO Max so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of big trailers coming soon we've got a
new Ant-Man in the WASP quantumania trailer video
coming tomorrow too of course I will do videos for
everything you've probably been seeing news about
this Harry Potter reboot in your feeds recently
supposedly leakers inside the studio reveal their
larger plans to basically start over from scratch
because of everything that's happened with
the franchise of the Harry Potter franchise in
general in their current run of spin-off movies
The Fantastic Beasts movies right now as of the
end of the Fantastic Beasts secrets of Dumbledore
the last couple years the studio says it has no
more fantastic Beast movies or movies of any kind
that are currently in development like the movies
have basically stalled out and they were meant
to be this huge Cash Cow for Warner Brothers they
made so much money on the original Harry Potter
franchise now this could always change like they
could have always make that next fantastic Beast
movie because originally they were supposed to
have committed to five of them but either through
a combination of people just losing interest in
the Fantastic Beast line of characters in the
movie is earning progressively less and less
money and all the drama with Johnny Depp Than
Ezra Miller and JK Rowling each on their own
each having separate PR nightmares my name is
Ezra Miller and I am criminally excited to be
a part of the Justice League in all the buyout
issues with Warner Brothers Discovery and a lot
of the Warner Brothers people getting fired
and new people getting hired on it just seems
like a lot of the new people that are coming
in now to work on this Harry Potter franchise
are getting ready to throw in the towel just
all the chaos from all these different fronts
and earning progressively less and less money
with the spin-off movies they're just ready
to pull a James gun like he's doing with the DC
movies and just completely wipe the Slate clean
what a week huh lemon it's Wednesday before all
the buyout nonsense with Warner Brothers Discovery
they seemed like they were going to pull a Star
Wars short term and just shift their short-term
efforts to the next few years on developing a
solid TV series set on another group of characters
I did a video about this a couple years ago at the
time my top picks were a Marauder series or like a
cursed child series that would allow cameos from
the original now older actors with the current
timeline still making sense like them trying to
do more core characters or characters that are
closer to the big ones in the original novels if
they do jump to a different part of the timeline
there's a ton of other stories inside the larger
Harry Potter Wizarding World universe that would
make for a solid TV series it's a little bit
easier to get away with stuff like that with TV
series than it is with movies and that could
still happen they could still be working on
that TV series the whole Discovery merger probably
just slowed down things a little bit even George R
Martin said that Game of Thrones was feeling the
penny pitching like the money issues with this
big merger that previously they had about nine
spin-offs prequels sequels for game of Thrones
that they were working on which includes House
of the Dragon which they're currently running
episodes for like I just did a bunch of House of
the Dragons season one episodes and because of the
merger they had to get rid of a couple of those
spin-offs the prequels that they were working on
but they still have a bunch of them that they're
working on so the same thing is happening for all
of Warner Brothers like anything that they own
or work on it's just been slowed down just like
a little bit but because of all this chaos the
people who are left still working at the studio
that haven't been fired yet are now doubling down
on their most profitable IP which includes the
original Harry Potter movies which is why you're
probably hearing more talk from inside the belly
of the Beast about them rebooting those original
movies they think doing that will ultimately be
more profitable than doing lesser separate
characters like Fantastic Beasts and they're
probably not totally wrong about that I enjoyed
the first fantastic Beast movie but I wasn't in
love with the characters I didn't like them the
same way that I enjoyed the original characters
also the writing is a big issue too the writing on
the original movies felt just way better because
they had and all that book material to adapt in
fact there was so much book material they had to
cut out a lot of it there were a lot of complaints
when the original movies came out it's just that
Twitter didn't exist till after the first couple
of movies had come out if social media had been
a bigger thing when the first couple movies came
out there would have been way more people yelling
about Harry Potter mostly about all the book stuff
that they had to cut out to fit the movies into
two two and a half hour runs but the idea was is
that because they had so much stuff to adapt it
just made for much better much stronger scripts
for the movies which is a very Game of Thrones
specific type of problem like the first couple
of seasons of Game of Thrones feel way stronger
because they're adapting direct book material
until we get to about season six where they
run out of book material and it starts to be
more original material which is why people say
season six season seven season eight of Game
of Thrones were way weaker than the previous
seasons and even though the original books were
fantastic it took years to finish those and way
more time went into them than was given to the
writing of the Fantastic Beasts movie and just in
general JK Rowling was given way more Authority in
writing the the Fantastic Beasts movie whereas she
was not during the original Harry Potter films
I believe part of her deal gave her some veto
powers on the original movies but because she was
so much less influential within the studio at the
time that the original movies were being made it
was much easier for the studio to bring in really
experienced writers to work on those with her and
when it came to Fantastic Beasts she had way more
power and way more Authority and it seems like
most of the movies were actually written by her
in most of her experience is in book writing not
in film and TV writing so that's why the Fantastic
Beasts movies just feel a little bit weaker no
surprise they aren't as good as the original
movies I'm not holding my breath right now for a
full reboot like right away because for instance
another Warner Brothers franchise movies Lord
of the Rings just a little bit older than the
Harry Potter films a little bit of overlap with
the first few ones but Warner Brothers has not
attempted to reboot those films mostly because
of Rights issues I think but also because the
originals were so good and so successful why would
you reboot something so quickly if the movies were
so good you you be cannibalizing a lot of your
sales and a lot of your fans of those original
movies I just did videos for the Amazon Lord
of the Rings TV series set during a completely
different part of the timeline in the second age
even Amazon though with their piles and piles
of money had trouble securing the rights for the
book material that covers the era of the timeline
that they are covering so just in general that
franchise Lord of the Rings franchise is kind of
a rights nightmare the reason why you're probably
hearing news of Harry Potter reboot plans and them
not pulling a Star Wars pivoting exclusive to TV
for a short period or jumping to a total different
part of the timeline like Lord of the Rings is
because there are no rights issues with the Harry
Potter franchise they on pretty much everything
exclusively although I do believe that part of
their deal with JK Rowling makes it so that she
does have a huge say in whatever they do wind up
doing with it and like I said because of all the
chaos on all different fronts all over the place
within Warner Brothers right now you have a lot of
new people coming in who are probably just wanting
to pull a James gun and wipe the Slate clean they
just think it's easier to just start completely
fresh kind of like them pulling a Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man to Andrew Garfield Spider-Man to Tom
Holland MCU Spider-Man if they do go for full-on
reboot I can't wait for all the Harry Potter into
the Potter versus jokes where they can pull
their own version of the Multiverse meme Harry
number one Harry number two and Harry number
three probably their safest bet though right
now would be to focus on stories and characters
who are much closer to the ones from the original
books outside of a full reboot some of the best
things that they could do would be to just move
the timeline forward a little bit and do like a
young Voldemort series they could do like a cursed
Child movie but the problem with that is it would
feel like a little bit more of a one-off and it's
kind of a weird situation because the whole idea
with the stage play is that all the characters
were played by completely different people like it
was a very wildly different casting for the same
core characters and it would be a little too weird
to do that in the movies like you need the same
actors coming back to play the characters play
the older versions of the characters in right now
one of the big issues that they've had with doing
Mainline movie is just set forward in the timeline
is it like half of the core actors don't want to
come back and and half of them do and how do you
do a Mainline movie set in the future without
like your most important characters like Harry
Potter himself best example of Daniel Radcliffe
Emma Watson both said repeatedly that they have
no desire to come back and it's not a money thing
like they have more money that they can spend in
their entire life the only reason they came back
recently was for the return to Hogwarts special
and that's because it wasn't an actual episode or
a movie it was just the actors coming together to
talk about how much fun they had making the
original movies and all their memories from
it made no mistake though they still got paid a
ton of money to do that would you like a giant
bag of money to come chat with your friends about
all the fun you had a couple years ago yes I will
take that money as far as I know Daniel Radcliffe
Emma Thompson like the other Mainline Harry Potter
actors seem relatively copacetic with the idea of
them rebooting eventually I think the question is
just how long they're going to wait before they
actually do do something like that right now
just feels like it's a little too soon for them
to do that we all remember the trauma from the
Spider-Man reboots like doing with Harry Potter
just is way different because there was so many
of those movie movies and they were so successful
and it was kind of the opposite situation with
the Spider-Man movies Sony rebooted so many
times because they felt like they had fizzled
out completely personally I think short term
they'd be better off just doing a large-scale
big budget Game of Thrones level TV series for a
few years set earlier on the timeline with core
actors like doing a young Marauder series or a
young Voldemort series they could do something
like that as more of a Breaking Bad show with an
anti-hero character descending into full-blown
villainy and at the end of the series just
making his horror cruxes then something like
a short time Jump at the end where he marks Harry
Potter as the final horcrux and then if they want
to after that then reboot the movies also doing
a TV series short term like the next couple of
years gives them time to try something during a
completely different part of the timeline and if
that does wind up being successful continuing
with that continuity so everyone let me know
in the comments what do you want them to do with
the future of the Harry Potter franchise like do
they do a TV series short term do they reboot the
movies do they do it completely separate group of
characters in a different part of the timeline
there's still a lot of options that they have
open to them and I'm not going to hold my breath
on a reboot happening in the next year or two of
course I'll do more videos for it when we get more
announcements but leave all your questions in the
comments below and like I said couple really big
trailers coming next week make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here to learn about Jessica Jones
coming back during Daredevil born again and click
here for my Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel series